[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec eve alpi
bonjour bonjour alors vous inviter à
montigny le bretonneux vous êtes
assistantes maternelles vous êtes aussi
aux tris de plusieurs romans
si c'est ça l'art quand vous est venue
l'idée d'écrire ça m'est venu assez tard
puisque j'écris que depuis huit ans
c'était je raconte une histoire mes
enfants on était à table c'était déjà
des grands enfants et c'est eux qui
m'ont poussée qui m'ont dit mais génial
ce histoire tu devrais l'écrire et comme
il savait que j'étais toujours avec un
livre dans la marne mais c'est dommage
de ne pas exploiter cette intrigue et
donc je me suis pourquoi pas je me suis
lancé un peu sur un défi je commence à
poser mes idées puis j'ai commencé à
écrire et et c'est là je me suis rendu
compte que j'aimais vraiment ça j'aimais
la lecture avant et puis je me suis mis
à aimer l'écriture je ne suis plus
jamais arrêter un foot est donc cette
histoire que vous aviez écrite
votre fils l'a édité en cachette c'est
ça donc elle s'appelle alors votre beau
finalement c'est un roman qu'est et qui
est venu quel est le lien avec saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est un c'est un roman qui se passe en
fait je veux pas faut les laisser ces
deux mondes parallèles dans un se passe
à saint quentin en yvelines
on y voit les commerçants de la marque
hayon et même le le centre commercial
c'est mon fils louis qui m'a fait
vraiment cette surprise de méditer moi
je me disais c'est même pas la peine
et puis d'ailleurs quand il l'a fait
c'était pour mon anniversaire il m'a dit
je t'ai jamais fait un aussi beau cadeau
parce qu'il y avait mis beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie et ça lui a
tellement plu que lui continue
maintenant dans l'édition
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire votre
prise a rejoint l'édition maintenant et
du coup vous avez lancé ensemble un
livre de recettes de cuisine biais dédié
être maman oui alors il faut dire que ma
mère mon n'est plus là et elle était
pétillante elle aimait faire la cuisine
pour ce pour sa famille ses amis
elle avait plein d'humour et donc on a
voulu faire un livre qu'il a reflété
donc on a essayé de mettre de l'humour
des anecdotes qui lui sont arrivés donc
à l mois nous et ce sont des recettes
familiales
on avait prévu un deuxième volume
malheureusement les partis mais là on va
peut-être s'y remettre et on disait que
on le referait pas ce qu'il allait quand
même beaucoup de succès pas seulement
famille les amis qui l'ont qu'ils ont
pris entre eux était très très très
chaleureux c'est familial
oui il ya aussi donc les romans amis à
trois tomes oui de quoi il parle
c'est une l'histoire d'une jeune fille
qui qui vit dans le nord de l'afrique et
qui est complètement sous l'emprise de
sa famille elle est maltraité et sa
belle-mère la somme de 7 de cette
famille ça c'est dans le off donc c'est
à nous libérer
puis dans le 2 la belle-fille et la
belle-mère 1 s'en vont en voyage et
traverse un pays en guerre
donc là je parle de la guerre et dans le
iii elle arrive en france où elle est
confrontée au racisme
et il faut dire que
je parle d'une jeune fille de 15 ans ça
se passe jusqu'à ses 17 ans à peu près
et pour moi c'est des enfants et donc
j'ai voulu un petit peu dénoncé ce qu'on
peut faire à des enfants ce que les
adultes il responsable peut faire à des
enfants et entre autres dans la guerre
je parle pas tant de la guerre que des
enfants qui souffrent de traumatismes
suite à des responsabilités d'adulte
c'est des sujets qui vous touche
oui oui oui ben je suis à 100 de
maternelle tout cas j'aime les enfants
j'aime j'aime les grands enfants même
les ados vous c'est
c'est ce que j'aime c'est des sujets qui
vous parlez encore plus les sujets
d'actualité finalement c'est où la
fiction mais parce que ça se passe en
2060 2500 d'autres et notre futur proche
mais c'est pas si proches que ça puisque
c'est après après une pénurie d'essence
et finalement l'actualité nous rattrape
parce que quand je les fais il ya huit
ans j'avais inventé des choses qui
existent aujourd'hui
mais comme des petites voitures qui
marche tout seul quand on a faim dit que
l'adresse et j'ai appris dernièrement
que ça existait déjà bon eh oui
finalement il y aura peut-être aussi de
d'autres choses c'est peut-être récurent
serre et donc il ya aussi eu un acheteur
il ya deux tomes oui oui et donc ça se
passe à la même époque à face à l'époque
d'ailleurs les les deux héroïnes se
rencontrent à un moment sans se
connaître vraiment il ya une petite mais
on peut lire indépendamment amis ou
hertz et c'est complètement différent et
ça parle de quoi
mercer ça parle d'un peuple qui est
sous la domination d'un autre d'un autre
peuple etc ça se passe à 50 km au-dessus
de la terre sur des plateformes une
plateforme en fait j'avais jamais vu
dans science et vie qu' il était
possible de faire ça pour économiser
justement au niveau de transport faire
des paquebots solaire des voyages et en
paquebot solaire et d'avoir des navettes
avec des plateformes tout autour de la
terre et donc ses romans et cinq romans
à qui s'adresse aux ados aux ados aux
jeunes au jeune john d'adultes et puis
j'ai même des personnes de mon âge qui
qui vont envoyer des gens petits
commentaires et qui ont bien aimé donc
que moi je dirai tout public à tout le
monde et donc vous avez aussi lancé là
dans une édition un peu différente
une série de nathan un personnage qui
s'appelle n'attendons qui à nathan et
les volets clos nathan et les sous-sols
interdite nathan et la clique le dernier
là qui va bientôt sortir nathan mène
l'enquêté
donc je faisais c'est notre maison s'est
dit c'est donc d'une autre maison
d'édition assez mal même format ce n'est
pas la même on a eu aussi normalement là
c'est en fait de quelqu'un d'une édition
chrétienne qui m'a contacté en disant
qu'ils avaient bien aimé mais mes
bouquins qui ne sont pas du tout à
connotation chrétienne cela mais ils
m'ont dit si je pouvais écrire pour les
enfants donc pendant quelques temps j'ai
réfléchi je me suis documenté j'ai
demandé à des enfants qu'est ce qu'ils
aimé lire tout ça j'ai lu beaucoup de
livres pour enfants que je me suis lancé
et j'avoue que ça m'a vraiment plu je
puis en plus c'est beaucoup plus légers
comme thème donc on arrive à mettre deux
places et de l'humour qu'on ne peut pas
placer forcément des dans des livres un
peu plus dramatique
vous vous aspirez de quoi pour ses
nattes ans et c'est quelqu'un que vous
connaissez c'est quelqu'un que plusieurs
personnes qui sont ensemble qui sont
rassemblés en attend finalement oui
c'est ça c'est exactement ça parce que
en fait dans le tout premier j'ai eu
envie de raconter l'histoire de mes
beaux parents
donc on va dire que datant c'est un
petit peu l'histoire de mon mari mais
pas vraiment parce que c'est pas la même
époque du tout et
il est complètement adapté mais c'est
vrai qu'à plein de petits clins d'oeil
qui sont vraiment et qui ont vraiment
existé
et puis il ya plein de petites choses
par exemple dans attend le sous-sol
interdit ça se passe dans une école il
faut dire que j'ai un enfant qui
animateurs et qui me raccompagnant
dimanche il m'a même photographié des
salles le plan de son école et qui m'a
je me suis inspiré vraiment de de tout
ce qui m'a donné et donc sous sol il
bien dans son école qui a été inondée
donc c'est rigolo quoi et j'ai fait de
la copie un petit peu j'ai pris de ci de
là mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
vrai et et vous parlez aussi quand même
de même si où il ya plus d'humour vous
parlez quand même deux sujets sensibles
qui peuvent aider aussi les enfants qui
lisent
oui oui c'est ça dans le deux bombes au
cfai qui sont des enfants qui font des
bêtises déjà dans ses enfants du mal à
vous leur faute ça donc j'ai une
certaine morale dans le iii
particulièrement je connais très bien un
jeune qui quand il était enfant caché ce
que ça ça moment il vivait seul avec sa
mère et sa mère buvait il en avait honte
et il ne disait pas et c'est vrai que
quand il s'est lâché
quand il a enfin dit même s'il n'avait
pas résolu son problème
il avait beaucoup mieux et voilà c'est
donc j'avais mis partager sa détresse ou
avoué une faute à la bonne personne et
toujours libérateur je me suis bon c'est
une petite morale mais disons que c'est
du roman plaisir avant tout et bien sûr
mais bon il ya quand même une petite
morale derrière et ça peut aider des
enfants qui se trouve le four en
difficulté et d'ailleurs donc c'est ses
romans nathan ils sont ils seront
bientôt disponibles normalement en livre
audio
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix en fait ça
m'est tombé dessus j'ai pas du tout fait
le choix c'est donc celui ci ma maison
d'édition est en partenariat avec un
institut pour aveugles et ils m'ont
demandé si
vous les biens donnés mes droits pour
que le livre soit lui pour des petits
ailleurs bien sûr j'ai dit oui avec un
grand enthousiasme j'étais vraiment au
doré qu'il prenne mon livre est comme il
cherchait les lecteurs ma fille s'est
proposé il se trouve que c'est là elle a
fait la faire donc elle a lu puis elle
est marrant parce qu'elle fait des axes
en effet l'accent du midi comme ça
c'était peut-être avant des personnages
elle avait joué le jeu et donc on n'a
pas encore de nouvelles sinon qu ils lui
ont dit que c'était très bien et qu'elle
se mette sur le 2 direct parce que c'est
quand même long à lire f cell soi et on
n'a pas de nouvelles mais on pense qu'il
va sortir
on est vraiment content de vous parler
de votre fille justement vous avez parlé
d'un de vos fils de l'autre fils c'est
une aventure familiale aussi
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que
d'ailleurs ils sont tous au courant que
vous venez et puis oui bon c'est vrai je
suis je suis une maman avant tout c'est
vrai je suis à 100 de maternelle donc
maman même de substitution pour les
petits que je garde et mes enfants se
sont bien impliqués d'ailleurs je les
remercie pour ça mais oui parce que
finalement il n'était pas du tout dans
le métier par votre fils d'homme dans
ses lancers l'organisation votre fils y
votre roman est tout le monde c'est
vraiment gentil faire l'indépendance
c'est pas du tout lucratif tout ce
qu'ils font c'est très gentil mais c'est
la passion et la roumaine et donc
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour la suite qu'est ce
qui arrive
un jeu plein d'idées j'ai plein d'idées
mais actuellement je suis en train de
terminer un robot et historique cette
fois ci est gelée se situe à l'époque de
louis xiv donc je me suis énormément
documenté et ça fait trois ans que je
suis dessus
donc c'était parallèle à d'autres parce
que c'est avec j'ai beaucoup beaucoup lu
beaucoup pris de notes j'ai rempli des
cahiers des photos on est allé à
versailles en italie et puis comme ça se
passe dans les cévennes j'en ai même
aller séjourner en dut
pour ce pour baigner dedans et ça se
passe donc du temps de la guerre des
camisards et des huguenots et donc c'est
en 10 702 le livre s'appellera 10 702
actuellement je peaufine les dialogues
pour leur donner une petite couleur
locale historique
voilà donc je refais tous les dialogues
est pourquoi d un livre historique après
des romans qui se passe finalement après
notre période actuelle j'avoue que je là
je sais pas ça me tomber dessus à cause
de versailles
on va souvent on est juste à côté on va
s'ouvrir au pas et d'ailleurs ça m'a
tellement plu puis j'ai tellement de
connaissances présentes sur le 14 que
j'ai envie de les 2 days devant servir
de nouveau et j'ai envie d'écrire
peut-être une autre série qui se massera
versailles pour des enfants cette fois
ci mais c'est pas encore fait mais 702
il devrait sortir quand je n'ai pas
encore soumis à la maison d'édition
qu'il veut qu'il arrive a dit qu'elle
voulait donc après c'est quand même long
ce serait aussi mois peut-être autrement
mais livrent donc se trouve se trouve
dans les librairies ou sur sur internet
n'a qu'en mai dans les librairies
j'aimerais vous dire qu'ils sont en tête
de gondole pas du tout c'est sûr et
c'est souvent sous sur demande voilà ou
sinon ici chez moi je suis répertoriés
chez eve alpilles avec google maps je
vous reçois un plaisir je reçois eu
plaisir des lecteurs
les futurs lecteurs eh ben c'est noté
merci beaucoup
et merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
émission se retrouve bientôt dans un
nouveau vip
il